decided by getting out Louis sisters
Karen James
miss James huh I hope you do know that I
very much regret what I did to your
brother
I was a very dumb kid when I did that
used to be the mayor right I heard you
was mad oh gee did my business
dignity self-respect let's choose the
time hold on
when you get out to 30 years I've tried
to use these years here to be a better
human being have you been thinking about
a job strategy
you're comfortable with reading and
writing
it's supposed to be bringing the whistle
in a piece throttle-body
seriously they'll do this you blip did
you brothers kill your beat your kid
it's gonna get patch it's in your best
interest to stay away from it may I say
something I'm sure that you are a
different person
but I don't want you to get
I can't buy my way out of your help I
know you know things you should with
made it fits it but the rest of people
there are many days that I've wondered
if you're right that this is where I
belong
you
[Music]